the reason the Press ignored the lab
leak stuff is because we funded the lab
and it was embarrassing and if we didn't
fund it it would be 100 of Americans
agreeing it most likely came from the
lab but it's it's insane that uh I mean
the video is fantastic it's insane that
the media literally said this and I have
people repeating it to me I had a friend
be like no I think it probably came from
the wet market and I'm like you think
the bat coronavirus didn't come from the
bat coronavirus laboratory it came from
the wet Market a block away from the
laboratory where someone drove a bat
from a thousand miles away to eat
instead of the lab where they had the
actual viruses that I you know that's
how I that's how I feel too I don't I
think that Donald Trump would get
pushback no matter what but I think that
because the U.S government was funding
the lab in Wuhan and the covet virus
likely came from the lab in Wuhan that
that is going to make the narrative
pushback the the the the significant
disaster